ladies secrets which sounds a lot worse  than what I meant  no Mean Girls okay surround yourself  around okay don't just find people all  during like orientation and only hang  out with them I had a roommate in  college who play I'm The Sims game very  loudly on her computer in the middle of  night and wake me up and she found some  cheat code to get a lot of money on it  so just hear it Jing Jing I'll get you a  Harry Potter appreciation Club stay up  late Club a beating Club maybe I just  made it up  flip-flops in the shower  maths books and alcohol is always good  we've gotten saved by Deanna who Melissa  McCarthy plays many times you need a mom  around people start putting qualifiers  on themselves when they're like 42 years  old and it's like you could live to 106  years old you're not even to the halfway  mark it's never too late he doesn't want  me to see it I don't see oh it totally  going  you